uh his football morning in america
column must read on
profootballtalk.com he is none other
than peter king my colleague at nbc
sports how are you peter
rich when i grow up i want to have
merchandise is that right
well if you want to when i grow up i
want to have merchandise
so you know like a like a peter king mug
or something like that
yeah yeah yeah i remember when i was on
your set
i took a rich eisen mug i don't know if
you realize that but
no we actually peter in my office i've
got a rich eisen mug right here you know
what peter uh it's wonderful to hear and
i know you're a big coffee guy so it
means a lot to me that you
five finger discounted that but we we
notice exactly who does
lift things from our set including
academy award winner
jk simmons not only lifted a mug he took
a coaster too
um we are very
we we keep a keen eye on our property
but it's all good
that's very good it's very good it's all
good
what a weekend no doubt man what an
incredible
weekend great game last night huh wasn't
that great
really a fantastic game i mean i
if you're a football fan you have got to
somehow hope that you know the
divisional round
in the afc has oakland going to
arrowhead
and not oakland but vegas going to
arrowhead how great would that be
amazing how great would that be it sure
would be
it sure would be especially since you
know uh we're assuming the steelers will
be sitting at the top and right now the
football gods
uh are seem to uh seem to have us put in
kansas city and pittsburgh for the mar
for all the afc marbles but obviously
there's there's so much more to go
before all of that
how do you see however that matching up
because that seems to me we've already
seen
you know kansas city against pretty much
everybody else um
in this conference how do you see that
one
matching up here
well i think what kansas city would need
to do
would be to get its offensive line back
intact
and to get that healthy before such a
game is played
because the one thing all the teams
that kansas city is going to play down
the stretch
with the possible exception of new
orleans and and look miami has a good
pass rush too
but it is in a pittsburgh pass rush
i honestly think kansas city can use
week 15 against new orleans as sort of a
measuring stick game for how they would
handle
the pittsburgh pass rush and and look
uh i don't think the steelers can
outscore the chiefs
but the steelers can score and
roethlisberger is
is obviously capable of putting 35 up on
everybody
but the question is
will patrick mahomes be bothered enough
uh by the pittsburgh defense i mean you
know rich
i talked to mahomes last night and i
said you know what was
what was great about this game is i said
you were behind uh in this game
uh and i'm gonna i'm gonna get the
scores probably slightly wrong but i
said
you're behind in this game 1714
24 in the second half 17 14
24 21 and 31 28 yes sir
and every time you responded with a
drive 93 yards
91 yards 77 yards
i mean patrick mahomes i'm just
i'm telling you we are seeing michael
jordan before our very eyes
it's just it's such a treat to watch the
guy play football
because it looks so effortless and we
know it's not and he does have the
weaponry
and he's obviously got uh the right
coach i mean it is
exactly what you need to have in this
league which is
the weaponry the consistency the mindset
the ability it really is a perfect storm
and in a spot where
you know they had been waiting a half a
century for the perfect storm to arrive
in the same way that we saw it arrived
in new england and
and other places in the nfl uh meanwhile
over in the nfc we saw
did did we just see uh a super bowl
contender
uh top seed in a conference basically
say
let's use a rivalry game as a laboratory
for the future to see who we've got in
taysom hill did do we really just see
that with sean payton
over there well rich i'll tell you i've
read a lot about this i've heard a lot
about this and
and i think i think you know i talked to
peyton last night
and he said here's exactly what happened
in the off season we told
taysom hill and we were excited about it
we told taysom hill
that he was going to get the first shot
basically
uh and uh and so
this this past week when they had to
make a decision
it really wasn't a decision for peyton
to make now
if jameis winston had blown them away
uh would they have had a decision to
make maybe
but he didn't and so they didn't
that's the first part of it i think the
second part of it is
you know i think there has been
much in the media said about the
inadequacies of taysom hill
and and all that and i think the biggest
reason is
because he has been seen
in cameos the whole time you know he's
like
sidra in seinfeld you know he
you don't you never see
uh you know a michael richards you you
don't see him play a season
on seinfeld you know you you just all
you see
is the occasional interesting
pop-up um you know like against the
vikings in the playoff game last year
but you
never see a 60-minute game
and you know i think it's fashionable in
our business as i say to say
because we haven't seen him do it he
can't do it
why you know one thing i told peyton
last night rich
is that uh in the in this at the
scouting combine in 2018
you know because you go there every year
you know the one thing about that that i
love
is that you run into somebody and say
hey
want to get a coffee or want to get a
beer and i just happen to walk
to see sean payton out on the sidewalk
in indianapolis
i said what are you doing right we're
right near starbucks hey let's get a
coffee and we went in there
and for like 45 minutes before his next
appointment
we talked and he told me the
the the tale of taysom hill
and how he was this guy who had been a
special teams guy for them that year but
he said
i honestly think this guy's got a chance
to be
our quarterback one day and i just
thought you know peyton is one of these
uh rube goldberg types sometimes
uh and i thought he i didn't think he
was kidding but i didn't really
know whether he was serious and every
time the subject has come up since
every time he's always said i'm telling
you
i know what i see and i see an every
down nfl quarterback
so rich i think it's it's silly
that when the opportunity comes up to
play him to
automatically need your go back to a guy
who's been a starter for five years like
like jameis winston
i'm not saying that if you had to play
jameis winston they wouldn't win with
him they probably would
but this is the guy who's been in line
for three years
and sean payton simply said i'm not
letting anybody cut the line
and now he is a winner even though i i
didn't notice
uh uh until i read your your your column
hill got the verbiage wrong in the first
play he called from from scrimmage he
did
yeah he was supposed to and this was the
this was the play that he and peyton
both absolutely loved and he said we're
going to call it because what peyton
wanted to do
at the start of this game he wanted to
give
uh the opportunity he didn't want taysom
hill to go
run the ball five times in his first
three series
so in his first 17 snaps he only ran it
one time
and that was by design payton wanted him
to play
quarterback and he wanted some some play
calls
early that he knew that would be a good
fit against the falcons
and uh and so this particular one he was
supposed to have michael thomas go into
motion
okay and he forgot to call the motion
in the huddle the excitement of the
moment
and so peyton is looking out and he sees
this
ball snapped he goes wait a second what
happened to the motion
and then he completes the pass and
obviously later he said what are you
doing he said i
and he just simply forgot to call the
motion so
but you know i said that it was a sign
of good karma they still gained eight
yards on the play and
and uh look he only had five
incompletions all day and two of them
were drops well and
and look uh he did score two with his
legs
and he did uh find uh
michael thomas for 104 yards and
targeted
him 12 times and camara scored and a
deep ball to emmanuel sanders for score
was called back
due to a penalty and the defense
smothered
the atlanta pass game so i mean it's all
good in the hood they're eight and two
and now
the question is is what about brees do
you think he does return after
two more ir games peter i get the
impression talking to the saints
that brees and their doctors believe
that it's not only realistic but
pragmatic
that he will come back flack jacketed
and play against philadelphia i think
it's week 14.
but and it's a big but i think peyton
is going to say the breeze the same
thing remember last year when brees
probably could have uh could have played
football uh before
you know he he actually came back and
but bridgewater was playing fine they're
winning hey get healthy get totally
healthy
the way i would do it if i were them i
would
look they've got three challenging games
the last three games of the year kansas
city and minnesota at home and then at
carolina
i think that you know if you can't win
against denver atlanta and philadelphia
in the next three weeks
and you don't feel confident enough to
win i wouldn't really
love my chances in january either so
i i think he's got a chance to play
against philadelphia but i think
they're going to play it by ear as to
how they're playing and how breeze is
healing
peter king here on the rich eisen show
next up as you mentioned
is at denver uh and the denver defense
certainly threw
a wrench uh on in the on the you know
onto the tracks of the tour train that i
have been riding on
um what'd you make of brian flores his
decision and just basically saying we're
gonna go back to him he's a tough kid we
i thought we needed a
a spark so on and so forth what'd you
think of that one
i think one of the worst cliches in
football and not just by the media
but by football teams is that well
you've put two you you've given a job to
tua
now you can't take them out why
is there a rule in the coaching rule
book that says
tua is going to shatter like a pane of
glass
if you take him out that he has no
confidence this is a guy who played for
friggin nick saban
i mean to think that some guy is going
to get
crushed mentally because
he gets pulled out of the game you know
what what happened yesterday reminds me
of when uh pick a great
goalie in the last few years in the nhl
if the rangers pull henrik lundqvist
uh in the middle of a game at calgary in
in january because he gave up five goals
in the first period
it's not your day buddy you're out bring
in
john doe here your backup i mean so what
they they they took the guy out he
wasn't playing well
and he'll be back next week i just think
sometimes we
invent rules in sports
that i always just say what
why is that an accepted part of doing
business
that now you can't yank tua because you
you know he
he you you gave him a starting job
there's no reason why you can't yank him
the same way that
there's no reason why you can't pull
ryan fitzpatrick in and out of the
lineup with need be
he's under contract you know i mean if
he if
if ryan fitzpatrick gets yanked his
feelings are heard definitely were
but if he is not going to accept his
role
see you later ryan we'll go get whoever
else
is out there well i guess the reason why
peter um
and trust me i have uh worked on game
day morning with uh
marshall faulk and warren sapp and i and
uh michael irvin
and the number of times that i've heard
them all say is how come quarterbacks
don't get treated like
every other position group in the nfl
where if you do not produce they should
you must you must sit and watch somebody
else who's on the depth chart next man
up like why
why do they get treated like a special
piece of of tiffany
uh or special piece of china like what
why why do they do that so i
i totally understand that um that said
that we have also seen locker rooms get
split right
where they're like well why why are we
going with that guy and not that guy or
that guy and not that guy or i'm more
that guy than that guy
so i guess this would be a test of brian
flores's uh
coaching acumen that has rightfully sung
had a lot of praises sung about it this
year right i mean like he must
know that he can toggle back and forth
between these two these two guys right
now
right i mean you don't even know if it's
going to be a toggle
maybe they put tua back in and he plays
the next six weeks
right and everybody lives happily ever
after
remember in 2003 when
uh the week before the regular season
the patriots cut
lawyer malloy tom jackson went on espn
that week
and said the patriots hate their coach
and buffalo beat new england in the
opener 31-0
well you know that year the patriots
went on
by the way in the last game of the
season the patriots beat the bills same
thirty one nothing and they went on to
win the super bowl
and and so that's why and i'm not saying
you look i think bill belichick has made
some mistakes
every coach does but what i'm saying is
that
i don't think there's any reason that
anybody in the miami locker room would
have to say oh my god two has been
perfect
and how in the world can you take them
out it's just
i just don't hear it i don't see it and
i doubt it's going to happen
peter king here on the rich eisen show
so then why um
stick with wence for as long as doug
peterson has stuck with him
to me right why can't he take the same
approach that you're saying right now
why i think it has to do with the fact
that the eagles are essentially stuck
with wence through the end of next year
he's got like a guaranteed
some like 26 million that he's owed
next year they're not going to be able
to to get rid of them
uh and i think they're really concerned
right now about his confidence level
they must be because otherwise why in
the world wouldn't you even entertain
the thought of playing jalen hurts
i certainly would you know we're getting
to the point now rich where
this is an absolutely awful
division as everybody knows but
somebody's going to make the playoffs
and somebody's going to get a home game
so let's say you're you're doug peterson
and your
your your howie roseman the gm you're
jeffrey lurie
in my opinion my biggest question would
be
we got seattle coming in this week
what gives us our best chance to win
against seattle this week now
it's unlikely they're going to win the
game anyway but you know every game is a
game
and what gives us the best chance to
beat seattle maybe they will come to the
conclusion that
that carson wentz does i would certainly
argue it's time to give carson wentz a
mental health break
you know taking that safety yesterday
was just
that's a freshman in high school move
right there
that was that was awful that was
you know you've got to know i can't get
tackled in the end zone
you know i you just got to get rid of
the ball so
but be that as it may anybody who's
watched the eagles play in the last
month
says there's something wrong with wence
you know
he needs a break i'd definitely
definitely play jalen hurts
uh with a couple you know a couple of
these
games down the stretch last one for you
peter is
uh the ravens have one of the top
organizations in the business as you
know from the owner to the president to
front office to the coach the word panic
normally wouldn't um
uh come to mind but how do they not uh
have a
a serious level of concern right now
that the way that this team has been
constituted
and built is a problem for this team in
2020 and how to fix it
for 2020 is a major rubik's cube to
figure out
the the worst thing for them yesterday
in my opinion i watch most of that game
the worst thing for them is that
you know it was brought home on the
non-tackle
of aj brown and
what was so incredible about that four
guys have a chance to tackle
hey look aj brown is is the
98 version of dk metcalf
so it's not like he's easy to bring down
but you're the baltimore ravens you were
the big bad
bullies you know of of of the of the afc
and you miss four tackles or four
opportunities to tackle
a receiver on at that moment the biggest
play in the game
i i look i'd be a little worried about
lamar jackson
i'd be worried about them offensively
not being able to dictate their will
uh on an opponent the way they did so
often last year
but man that was a worrisome thing to me
when i saw that they didn't tackle aj
brown yesterday so
i think they got a lot to worry about
you can't really do much in a short week
rich i know
you know they're they're six and four
and as you say
they have to win this because look they
got pittsburgh
and then the following thursday they've
got dallas and then
a sneaky tough game at cleveland the
following week monday night so
there is absolutely no guarantee
that they're going to make the playoffs
right now if i looked at
the three teams in the afc
that are better right now today in the
wild card race
vegas definitely better tennessee
better miami probably better
cleveland may be better so i mean
they've got to find somebody who they
can beat right now and especially rich
the one other thing
they have a four and four conference
record i mean
they've got four conference losses if
they lose to pittsburgh
they will they would lose a tiebreaker
to almost
every team in the afc so i mean
you know that's why this game in
pittsburgh is so much more important
than just
getting back on the right track five
conference losses
how do you win tiebreakers with five
conference losses
it is so huge on thanksgiving night and
uh their next three games as you
we've just pointed out are all in front
of the whole country to see
thanksgiving night on nbc and then the
triple cast
uh thursday night opener to week 13
against dallas and then monday night on
espn against cleveland
it is on and cracking for the ravens
thanks for the call peter happy
uh thanksgiving to you and your family
let's chat again soon
thank you thanks very much rich all the
best you're the best enjoy the mug
enjoy the mug peter it's peter king
right here hey you watched all the way
to the end thanks for that
watch more right here